der mexikaner ball
hallo mein name ist ralf kabelka und die
preise für die heute show in die usa um
donald trump und sein neues amerika
kennen gelernt meine erfahrung habe ich
so kommentiert als euer ganz
persönliches locker
[Musik]
1 0
neu von deutschland eine ehemalige
teilnehmerin deutschland reality show
the apprentice behauptet deutschland wie
bei einem intimen verleiht weit war an
die wand im rücken hat ihrem großen
gefahr kreis das ist natürlich eine
sache die fragen aufwerfen wenn diese
ganzen reihe nur einfach ein schrei nach
liebe kundenwunsch
einfach nur mal liebt ja überhaupt nicht
psychologisch und ist der wunsch
amerikanischer präsident zu werden
was normalerweise glücklosen
frauenkörpern gemacht dass jetzt
wirklich angesagt ist der neuen zeit in
der tram zeit das sind sachen die auch
wieder amerika nach vorne bringen die
einfach toll auch wieder schöner als
diesel kommen obwohl wahrscheinlich eher